I'm Dr Filer and my goal is to heal your
mind and reintegrate you into society as
soon as possible I'm not insane stay
calm
wait you're making a
mistake after 18 months today's the big
day 18 months are you okay Stephen I
saved you from years in
prison I really don't remember thing
baby stepen no nothing doctor said one
every morning I'm
fine something's not
right father please go
now I just got this awful
feeling it's all coming back I'm not the
person that I thought I was I want to
know exactly what's going on you're
mistaking dreams for
memories these aren't
dreams
not making any
sense I feel like I'm
C I'm here but I'm not
here it's a sick experiment the doctor
said this might
happen I'm not going to hurt you Steven
maybe it's time we call a doctor how
long we've been friends how long we've
been friends I honestly can't even
remember well that's
right I'm innocent my mind was never
yours you remember what we want you to
remember I know what they're doing here
wake
up close your eyes and relax we'll get
started